au lendemain de la journée de la femme
nous vous proposons ce soir le
témoignage de l'une d'entre elles âgée
de 71 ans elle a été séquestrée et
agressée sexuellement par un de ses
voisins de palier pour ne pas laisser ce
crime impuni
elle a choisi d'en parler comme pour se
libérer d'un poids
lucas chopin a recueilli ses paroles
marie à 71 ans au moment du drame
un samedi de janvier elle ouvre la porte
de son appartement intrigué par du bruit
dans le couloir au même moment un homme
sort du logement d'en face un squat il
pénètre chez elle ferme la porte à clé
et lui bondi dessus et m'a embrassé une
brèche comme un animal et jeholet et
puis il m'embrassait pourront pêcher
crier c'était offre cette offre april a
soulevé mon pull ça a été la poitrine
s'est attardé sur ma poitrine les plus
bas b il n'a pas pu et puis il est parti
j'étais ce tremblay je ne pouvais plus
marcher je tremblais c'était affreux
une enquête est en cours pour tenter de
retrouver l'agresseur qui s'est
volatilisé en attendant marie tente de
se reconstruire
elle n'a plus d'appétit et de retrait
mal les pubs j'adore je fais des
cauchemars je me réveille même où on ne
court après on veut me tuer c'est
finalement quand on ne rattrape je me
réveille en faisant un grand bien dans
mon lit et je me réveille en soeur comme
de nombreuses victimes marie et démunis
elle doit maintenant s'atteler aux
démarches judiciaires et psychologique
des associations comme france victimes
sont là pour aider les personnes dans
son cas elle ce dont elle a besoin c'est
d'être prises en charge dans les
premières démarches à faire parce que
quand ça vous arrive ya effectivement
une sidération il ya une impossibilité à
réagir et donc on a besoin que quelqu'un
vous dit danser dans ses démarches la
cie a besoin d'une prise en charge
psychologique
elle peut venir dans un second temps
l'an dernier le nombre de violences
sexuelles a augmenté de 3% en france une
augmentation limitée par les
confinements